failed former president Donald Trump
once arrested twice impeached has been
indicted a second time this time
federally he will be arrested and booked
on Tuesday in Miami at 3 P.M Eastern
Time ladies and gentlemen it is
happening and it is even more
unprecedented if you can if you can even
say such a such a thing
um wow what a day what a night CNBC
report
ex-president's arraignment comes day
before his birthday Donald Trump has
become the first U.S president former or
otherwise to be indicted on federal
criminal charges Trump announced in
Thursday night posts on his truth social
platform that prosecutors notified his
attorneys he had been indicted NBC News
confirmed soon after that
he faces seven charges including making
false statements conspiracy to obstruct
according to Trump's own lawyer James
trustee
the charges also include willfully
retaining documents in violation of the
Espionage Act
Trump the leading Contender for the GOP
Presidential nomination is scheduled to
appear Tuesday at a federal courthouse
in Miami the former president had kept
reams of classified documents and boxes
at his Mar-A-Lago Resort in South
Florida until federal agents raided it
last year and seized the records Trump
says he's innocent and ripped the case
as a hoax it is very important to
understand a number of distinctions
between this and what is happening with
the indictment and arrest in New York
the New York arrest is on state charges
this is a Federal indictment this is not
necessarily the only Federal indictment
that Donald Trump is facing because this
is only related to the documents there
is also a federal investigation
going on into Donald Trump's role in
inciting the Trump Riots of January 6
2021 no charging decision has been made
there and at minimum there are
additional State charges possible
against Donald Trump in the state of
Georgia we will learn more about that
sometime between I believe the dates are
July 11 and September 1st or July 1st
and September 11th something along those
lines none of this none of this is at
this time evidently politically
motivated
a Witch Hunt a perversion of the justice
system or anything like that we're going
to delve into those aspects in details
but Trump indicted federally historic
days in the United States let's now go
to Donald Trump's reaction